bonjour david capitan merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors on
l'a dit est les verts le parti
écologiste allemand devant frais selon
un sondage la cd ou le fameux parti
conservateur pour la course à la
chancellerie
comment vous expliquez cette percée des
verts en allemagne
c'est une percée des verts qu'ils
expliquent je crois par deux facteurs
principaux le facteur le plus le plus
évident c'était évidemment la baisse des
partis classiques
alors vous savez que l'allemagne est
gouvernée actuellement par ce qu'on
appelle une grande coalition qui
regroupe le parti social-démocrate donc
là la gauche classique et puis le parti
la ccd août s'est assoupi et le parti
d'angela merkel ce jour du pouvoir se
fait sentir et il ya donc une baisse est
partie des partis classiques de la
gauche comme de la droite
cette baisse profite évidemment aux
autres partis qui peuvent représenter
une alternative 3 principalement donc
l'extrême droite de la sd le parti
classique centrale libéral qui est le
fdp est le parti des verts qui est un
petit peu le nouveau venu
ce qu'il faut noter c'est que parmi ces
trois partis qui gagne effectivement les
voix que perdent les partis classiques
et bien les verts font vraiment la
marche en avant si la sève des gagne un
tout petit peu le fdp également les
verts au contraire au temps de ranger
les voix qui font défaut aujourd'hui à
la de céder ou et et au spd
évidemment on peut se poser la question
de savoir ce qui a conduit à cette
baisse des partis classiques au delà de
de l'usure du pouvoir
cela dépend des partis si on prend le
parti de la chancelière angela merkel il
ya évidemment le fait que l a régné
pendant quatre mandats sur ce parti est
absolument sans partage que son départ
parce qu'elle ne se représentera pas eh
bien allez c'est un chant en nouveau une
certaine incertitude sans doute là la
figure qu'elle représentait de
continuité a valu le soutien une partie
des électeurs à son parti aujourd'hui
elle s'en va et il faut donc la
remplacer ce qui en terme de personne
n'est pas
extrêmement simple donc ça c'est un
élément évidemment important on peut
aussi compter sur les difficultés que
l'accès des ou a pu rencontrer pour
désigner justement le chancelier
potentiel en tout cas la tête de liste
de ce parti et on a entendu les
dernières semaines qu'entre armin
laschet tu qui est le candidat qui a
finalement été retenu et le ministre
président de bavière est bien la
question n'a pas été extrêmement clair
on s'interroge sur le fait de savoir si
de tête de liste de la td ou et là la
bonne personne ce que c'est quelqu'un
qui a le charisme suffisant
justement david david capy temps je
voulais vous poser une question au sujet
d' anna lena berloquin avait été désigné
justement pour pour représenter le camp
écologiste lors de ses prochaines
élections légistatives pourquoi elle
précisément alors il faut dire que le
choix de l'énap barbeuk a été vraiment
résultat extrêmement unanime de la part
du parti ce qui est lui donne évidemment
en contrepoint des difficultés contre la
cd ou un élément beaucoup plus favorable
ces tunnels représente vraiment je crois
une figure de deux changements elle a 40
ans est une ancienne sportive
il est vrai qu'elle n'a pas énormément
d'expérience elle n'a pas été ministre
même au niveau des länder allemands qui
disposent chacun d'un gouvernement et
d'un parlement
elle est députée en revanche au
bundestag locale a une certaine
expérience de la vie politique au niveau
national
d'autre part elle a participé ces
notables aux négociations qui ont eu
lieu en 2017
après les dernières élections allemagne
allemande avant que la grande coalition
de se reforme il avait été envisagé que
le late cd ou puisse éventuellement
faire une coalition avec le parti
libéral et le parti vert et elle a
participé assez assez assez négociations
ce qui lui donne tout de même une
certaine connaissance des mécanismes
centraux du gouvernement en allemagne
des mécanismes fédéraux cela dit c'est
un binôme et qui est à la tête du parti
et elle représente peut-être par rapport
à monsieur avec qui était le seul autre
enfin qui est actuellement le président
du parti et qui était également candidat
pour être le futur candidat des verts
et bien ne représente peut-être plus
grande jeunesse et puis un côté
peut-être plus pragmatique qui
correspond bien à l'image politique de
ce parti
car en effet ce qui fait la une grande
force des verts dans le paysage
politique allemand c'est à la fois
qu'ils sont une force de renouvellement
mais en même temps une force pragmatique
et ce pragmatisme les distingue par
exemple de la sd du parti d'extrême
droite qui a connu un certain succès au
moment où les thématiques des des
migrants étaient au premier plan mais
aujourd'hui cette thématique n'est plus
au premier plan de l'actualité des
préoccupations des allemands et sur le
reste et bien le parti d'extrême droite
semble prendre un un mouvement qui n'est
plus très sérieux qui correspondrait au
gilet jaune français en étant anti
europe anti masque
enfin un certain nombre de sujets alors
qu'au contraire le parti vert est bien
lui a fait preuve d'un grand pragmatisme
la dernière question très rapidement
avant nous nous quitter david capy temps
vous parliez tout à l'heure du parti
écologiste qui effectue on le voit une
réelle percée contrairement aux autres
partis entre guillemets plus la plus
traditionnelle est ce que à votre avis
est très rapidement les verts ont une
réelle chance à ces élections
législatives au mois de septembre
mais oui ça absolument parce que le
système en allemagne et un système
d'abord qui est proportionnel donc tous
les partis sont représentés au parlement
puis d'autre part c'est un système dans
lequel on élit d'abord le parlement et
c'est le parlement qui choisit le
chancelier si par conséquent le parti
vert arrive avec 30% ce qui n'est pas du
tout inatteignable la première place
dans les partis politiques et bien il
sera sans doute dans la coalition ça
très certainement
et s'il est le premier parti il pourra
réclamer le poste de chancelier
la question reste alors de savoir quelle
coalition sera formée en effet le parti
écologique actuellement participa à 11
coalition dans les 16 m
allemand parfois avec les partis de
droite parfois avec les partis de gauche
et donc évidemment cette période de
campagne électorale
et bien tout reste ouvert le parti vert
ne ne prend pas de partie sur la la
coalition qu'il pourra former car en
effet il s'agit pour l'instant d'attirer
le maximum d'électeurs lors de la
prochaine campagne
enfin lors de la prochaine élection qui
aura lieu le 26 sept ans
merci beaucoup david capy temps d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur rtl france et
d'avoir également répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'université
franco-allemande merci beaucoup